2022 is shaping up to be the most
interesting year in the history of the
electric vehicle industry
last year in 2021 americans bought about
440 000
battery electric cars and suvs and this
year the growth could be quite
significant up anywhere between 40 and
50 percent now that's still a relatively
small portion of overall sales
last year the ev market accounted for
only about three percent of new vehicle
sales if things go well
this year it could approach five percent
but still a relatively small portion and
fewer than a million units are expected
to be sold this year nevertheless
there's so much activity in the space
and as a result by the end of this
decade in the late
2020s and by 2030 electric vehicles are
expected to account for at least half if
not more of all
new vehicle sales in the united states
one of the key areas to watch this year
will be pickup trucks tesla excited
people a few years ago when it unveiled
its cyber truck a reimagined version of
what a pickup truck of the future could
look like in 2022 there's still no cyber
truck and elon musk said last month in
january
that there will be no cyber truck this
year perhaps it'll be ready by 2023.
we'll see tesla made a decision this
year not to introduce any new vehicles
so for the time being its core uh
business will revolve around the model y
crossover and the model 3 sedan as a
result he's creating an opportunity for
some big rivals that are very powerful
in the pickup truck space in particular
ford and general motors
both companies have major releases in
particular the one that's coming first
and coming fastest will be the ford
f-150 lightning the f-150 is the
best-selling vehicle in the united
states and has been for decades
ford sells nearly a million pickup
trucks in an average year and there's a
lot of excitement about the f-150
lightning pricing on it is fairly
attractive starting at around forty
thousand dollars for a basic model and
that's before any government incentives
as a result ford has announced that it's
got more than two hundred thousand
reservations for the lightning so
there's no shortage of demand the
critical issue for ford is going to be
how quickly can they actually build
the truck and get it to their customers
general motors also has an electric
version of the silverado the chevy
silverado pickup
and gm has said it's got more than 110
000 reservations for that those numbers
are smaller than what tesla appears to
have for cyber truck which are anywhere
between 250 thousand three hundred
thousand but again the issue with the
cyber truck is we don't know when it's
going to actually come to market so
strategically this could be
a challenge for tesla over the next
couple of years since elon musk is
allowing two major competitors to move
in to and define the pickup truck market
ahead of tesla
in general
the the key factor that we're going to
see
in the ev space will be
a range of new models across the
spectrum from some relatively affordable
ones to some very high-end vehicles at
the end of 2021 we saw startups
including rivian's electric pickup truck
and electric suv retailing for about 80
or 90 thousand dollars with options
lucid with its air sedan is at an even
higher price point in the 130 to 140 000
range what we'll see in 2022 will be a
wider assortment of more affordable
middle of the market electric vehicles
kia and hyundai are coming out with the
ioniq 5 and kia's ev6 this year
those will be in the 40 000 40 to 50 000
price range a bit above the average new
vehicle but still a bit more attainable
than perhaps the rivian or lucid models
volkswagen will also continue to expand
production and supply of its id4
a crossover hatchback that it introduced
last year that's also going to be
targeting buyers in that forty thousand
dollar price range or so tax incentives
both from the federal government and in
some states such as california can shave
off up to ten thousand dollars off that
purchase price so that will make them
much more attractive the other factor
that's going to be very fascinating to
watch will be the federal push to expand
electric vehicle charging infrastructure
in february the biden administration
began to open up access to at least five
billion dollars of federal funds to get
at least half a million of these high
volume high output dc fast charging
stations built
and
set up along major u.s highway corridors
making it possible for anyone who owns
an ev to consider taking their car on
cross-country trips something that's a
little more challenging now for anyone
other than tesla owners because tesla
already has its own
nationwide network of supercharging
stations so there's going to be a lot of
activity in 2022 it's going to be a
transitional year for the market with
many new players many new products and
everyone is going to be targeting tesla
in the end this will benefit the overall
industry with a lot more production
domestically in the united states of
batteries and electric vehicles and
hopefully as more of these vehicles get
on the road we see an overall drop
in carbon emissions which is ultimately
the promise of
all of these new battery-powered
vehicles
[Music]
you